John Stuart Mill was an extraordinary and
influential thinker in the early 19th century
in England.
He was something of a radical within his society
at the time and, as a consequence, was very
interested in the ability to to develop and
communicate radical ideas that were outside
the mainstream, because he was interested
in a lot of those ideas himself, and he was
much more interested in how a free society
should operate the ability of people to think
for themselves in a free society, and sometimes
run against the grain of public opinion and
mainstream thought in general.
He offered a variety of arguments about why
it is we ought to value that kind of speech,
those kinds of spaces, that kind of robust
debate.
So one of those arguments I characterize as
an argument driven by humility.
That is, that part of what Mill wanted to
remind us is that we all might be mistaken,
that our own understanding is limited.
Our own set of ideas are very limited.
And that we can learn from each other.
And we can learn from others who have different
ideas than ourselves.
But that requires some willingness to accept
the possibility that we, in fact, might be
mistaken.
And of course, we walk around most of the
time with the belief that we are upholding
a set of correct ideas, that we think we know
our own minds.
We think the ideas we hold are true.
That's why we hold them in the first place.
And so it can be challenging to go into a
conversation and go into a discussion, go
into a public space and accept the possibility
that we might be wrong.
But Mill wanted to emphasize that it's only
by accepting that possibility that we're wrong
that we can have the opportunity to learn.
And it's important for our own sake that we
be able to continue to learn and grow by talking
to people with different ideas and being genuinely
open to the possibility that they might persuade
us.
They might show the flaws in our ideas.
They might expose our mistakes.
And as a consequence, they might help us make
progress.
But he also constructs an argument that's
really grounded instead on a concern with
arrogance of others.
Here, the concern is not so much that we be
willing to hear from people that we disagree
with because we accept the possibility that
we might be wrong.
But instead, he wants to speak to our instincts
to want to suppress opinions that we find
disagreeable or dangerous so that no one else
can hear them, instead.
And this is fundamentally a paternalistic
concern, a concern that we're worried about
other people, that they might be misled by
bad ideas.
And so even if we think that we ourselves
are capable of separating good ideas from
bad ideas, and so as consequence, we should
be able to hear a wide range of views and
arguments, we might be much less comfortable
that other people can make the same distinctions,
will come to good decisions, exercise good
judgment when listening to those ideas.
And so as a consequence, there's a certain
arrogance where we want to impose our own
beliefs on others and shield them from the
opposition; shield them from listening to
the critics so that the only voices they hear
are our own.
And it's difficult to resist that tendency
and that instinct, precisely because when
we're thinking about what ideas in society
we find as wrongheaded, disturbing, maybe
dangerous, it becomes all the more tempting
to think, when confronted with that dangerous
idea, that we shouldn't expose anyone else
to that dangerous idea because they might
be polluted by it.
They might believe it.
And they might even want to act on it.
And finally, Mill offers an argument that
I characterize as an argument from conviction,
which is to say that he says, we have a set
of ideas that we walk around with.
And we think they're probably right.
We assume oftentimes they're right; we haven't
thought about them very carefully.
And they may be very deeply held ideas.
They may be central to our belief system,
our value system.
More generally, they may be crucial to how
we think about the world and how it operates,
more generally.
But oftentimes, we don't have a lot of reason
to think about those ideas very carefully.
We haven't explored them or thought about
them very carefully ourselves.
Instead, we've received them from others.
We've taken it for granted they're probably
true, and we've moved on.
But he emphasizes that we don't really know
how true those ideas are.
We don't know how confident we ought to be
about the truth of those ideas until we've
seen them tested in intellectual battle, and
until we've seen critics go after them with
hard arguments, with counter evidence, with
objections, and we've seen how well those
ideas can weather that kind of storm.
Can our ideas stand up to criticism and skeptical
inquiry?
And he says we shouldn't be very confident
in ideas that we are not willing to expose
to those kind of criticisms.
That it's precisely the ideas that we've seen
weather the criticism that we ought to be
confident about.
And so as a consequence he encourages us to
think that if we want to have real confidence
in our beliefs as individuals, but also as
a society, that we should be particularly
willing to expose our ideas to the harshest
critics we can find because those critics
will help us, and they will help us be more
confident in the strength of our own ideas.
And sometimes they will also show us the weaknesses
of our ideas and force us, then, to think
more carefully about them and force us to
build better and more robust supports for
those ideas.
So we will come away more sophisticated thinkers
with more carefully held and carefully considered
ideas than we went into those conversations
with.